has this political Trailblazer trashed
her own reputation Diane Abbott was
Britain's first black woman MP but after
Decades of speaking out about racism an
intervention on that very topic has
attracted almost Universal condemnation
I woke up today
and I read the letter in the Observer
written by Diane Abbott and Beggars
believe
the comments from Dan Abbott are simply
unacceptable in a letter in today's
Observer newspaper she wrote that Irish
Jewish and traveler people undoubtedly
experienced Prejudice this is similar to
racism and the two words are often used
as if they are interchangeable it is
true that many types of white people
with points of difference such as
redheads can experience this Prejudice
but they are not all their lives subject
to racism
after a backlash Diane Abbott swiftly
apologized and withdrew the comments but
she's had the labor whip suspended
meaning she's now an independent MP
her own Hackney constituency includes
one of the largest Orthodox Jewish
communities in Europe do you think what
Diane Abbott said is anti-Semitic
definitely I mean there's no question
about it how can it not be but some are
supportive of their local MP I know
she's helped a lot of people in the
Jewish community in the past
so for a second I would not think that
you meant what you said
in her apology Diana Abbott says an
early draft of her letter was sent in
error but even that admission provokes
yet more questions and there are now
growing calls including from the
campaign against anti-Semitism first of
expelled from the labor party if that
happens or even if the whip just remains
suspended Diane Abbott's 36 years
representing this community may soon be
over
under my leadership there will be Zero
Tolerance of anti-Semitism of racism of
discrimination of any kind the
supporters of kirstama say he's been
true to his word
he once worked side by side with Diane
Abbott and Jeremy corbyn now neither our
labor MPS and both could be out of
parliament at the next election Joe Pike
Sky News Hackney